那么说非常危的方式。
怎么理解这个非常规的方式啊？同学们。
我给大家把这个知识。
往简单里讲。
便于大家去理解。其实非常规的方式就是什么啊？
就是你这个开场。
用常规方式的建制。
没有亮点。
真的是没有亮点。
没有拿人的东西。
那我从别的地方挑一个拿人的东西行不行，对不对？我从别的地方挑一个拿人的东西行不行？
还行。
有时候真的就行。
从别的地方。
挑一段。
或者挑一个拿人的点一场戏。
往帘一放。
对吧。
我们说。
我们说那个呢隐秘的角落。
隐秘的角落。
秦昊这个角色在山上一下把他。
父母我们暂定暂时理解为父母推下去。
这不是正常的叙事顺序。
你得先讲他是谁。
对吧生活状况是什么样的，性格是什么样的，跟父母的关系是什么样？
然后甚至要讲一下他父母他们三个人之间的关系。
原因是什么？然后为什么把他们推下去，这才是正常顺序。那现在他直接推。
因为我们看过后面的故事了啊，我这里不剧透。但是我们看过后面的故事，知道其实其实把它推下去。
这个举动就秦昊把这个父母二老推下山，在整个故事里面算是激励世界。
就是他因为把这两个人推下去。
所以导致了后面。
一系列的情况。
所以。
我们先。
比如说。
第一种情况。
就是你如果积累事件。
特别那啥。
你可以提。
你可以提到开场。
这种操作挺多的。
为啥呢？因为不难，就是说他不那么绕。
他不太绕。
因为我们正常讲故事啊，铺垫完了就是激励实线。
等于是你把基地就这个挪动的范围不是特别大，你知道吧？对故事整个来说没有大动。
因为你铺垫完了直接就激励了。
有很多故事，甚至边铺垫就边激励了。
对吧你如果我举个例子，我说你如果讲一个小孩，他生活特别可怜呃，父母对他不好，然后他后面想要他后面的行为是离家出走，那你可以考上来就开始对他不好，就上来这个现状就不好，就一直在激励都可以。所以说我们说激励激励事件提前其实挺常用的，并不罕见。
我们举几个例子。
除了这个隐秘的角落啊。
嗯。
我印象比较深的啊，年轻的时候我喜欢看的剧，比如说有个美剧叫外包服务。
外包服务。
讲的是啥呢？讲的是一个美国小伙子。
去印度。
工作的。
各种有趣的事儿，喜剧。
开场是啥呢？开场就是他去上班。
哼着歌，电梯一开诶。
公司一个人也没有。
然后往里走，长长的走廊走进去，他老板一个人坐在里面，然后告诉他。
哎呀，忘了告诉你了。
咱们公司所有的人都被我开掉了，然后呢，我们把公司全部的业务包给印度了。
因为美国有很多那种业务是包给印度的，为啥呢？因为印度人说英语嘛。
他们是一个电话购物的一个公司。
就所有的公司的人都是接电话下单卖东西。
然后他就是。
我们公司全部的业务都报给印度了，所以所有人都被我开除了，就剩你一个。
你现在有两条路，呃，我现在要派你去印度。
那个那个工作，然后对于一个美国小伙子来说，他肯定不愿意去嘛，他说我不愿意去。然后那个老板就说那第二条路就是你你也被开除。
我也无所谓了。然后下一个镜头就是他在印度的街头坐的那个印度的小三轮车，滴滴滴在那个人流当中找他的公司。
Management training.
What happened?
Where is everybody costs were through the roof, you know, pensions, healthcare care, we had to do a little right sizing but there's no one here exactly that's what makes us the right size yesterday we outsourced the entire call center to India.
拜。
You bastard that's for me wait wait a minute, Jerry, I went through trainings specifically to run this call center, I know, and we still want you to run the call center in India.
You want me to go to India, Todd, if you do this for the company, we're going to bump you up to vice president.
If you don't, well, we're already the right size, there are no more positions here, wait, so you saying go to India or I'm out of a job?
I worked hard for this company, I was the best salesman.
You know what, who's to say I'm not going to go out there and start my own novelties company huh Don't you owe like 40 grand in student loans?
。
This is insane, it's like it's like frogger, but with real people.
这个开场就是个激利事件，就是公司黄了，被迫全部搬到印度去。他要去印度当项目经理。
这就是激励实践开场。
对吧跟这这个隐秘的角落，其实原理是一样，就很有意思。
还有那个比如说像。
啊，去年有一个英剧叫保镖。
挺有意思的。
男主角就是这个保镖嘛，男主角就是一个退伍的这个这个前特种兵还是什么，反正是很牛逼的一个士兵。
开场就是他在火车上，这个火车上有炸弹。
他带着一堆儿女在这个火车上。
乘蹭火车，然后火车上出现了恐怖袭击，有炸弹，然后他要处理这个事情。
有是要放陪那个了，没有言。
给给了。
是是是。
别来 to sleep。
我。
到底妈什。
You wouldn't to my kids for a minute with you, I'll be right back, no problem Thank you very much I'll be right back.
Lookant David by the metropolitan Police, what's going on?
You've got an intelligence report from Asian meal in his twenties0s.
I do you know about that saw you checking at the guy in my carriage, he's fine but I saw someone that tends suspiciously at Marston, I don't know if he succeeded in boarding the dream, but if you dad he could be in the toilet.
Look, I'm an operational firearms commander with Special Proction, what's the plan?
British transport have alert on possible we' London've been ordered to train Barnett shed's derelic depot theO9 they've been board the train How long do we get there?
S minutes give onede in the toilet and went to the carriage for maximum casual.
stick with me and's what your name Sandra, give me number.
Oh, double70900876 I need to call this in.
就是开场就激励啊，你并没有去讲这个男主角，他以前是一个什么样的兵，他有什么样的性格，他有什么样的这个这个缺陷，他有什么样的技能都不讲，都不用讲，也不需要讲呃，这是呃大环境是什么，对吧？英国为什么会有这个恐怖袭击，不需要讲，就上来就是火车上。
有炸弹。
就是激励事件开场。你如果激励事件够精彩，够拿人儿，你完全可以用它来开场。
而且我说的这个调动幅度不大呀。
因为你看啊我们说常规的上来士铺垫，那非常规其实就是从后面吊一场。
调一个玩意儿过来嘛，相当于什么呢？就是我为什么说同学们先跟我学正常的叙事方式，然后我们再来慢慢的研究发展变化。
正常的叙事方式不就是先建制，对吧？然后把这全部呃这个事情铺垫明白了，然后再激励一下，然后再进入冲突，然后再发展故事，然后再怎么样有一个正常的顺序。
然后呢，你在非常规的情况下没有那么复杂。你前面那种学会了，用熟了，你非常规你不会觉得复杂的。你就是把来激励实验挺有意思，但我拿过来先用一用。
我开场就有。
先鸡嘛。
先挤着。
吸引一下眼球。
这戏手年来了，举的都是美剧的例子。我再给大家举个电影的例子。
金世漂流记。
韩国电影我建议大家一定要去看一下这个电影的剧本是一个满分级别的剧本。
满分级别的剧。
很典型，吉励世界开场这个故事讲什么？我大概说一下啊。
就是一个中年男人生活很不如意，很落魄，然后呢决定自杀。
决定自杀，然后跳江，从大桥上跳江，跳下去之后呢没死。
没死飘到了这个。
湖心道上。
就是你看啊很宽的大河，它不是有个大桥嘛？那个大桥桥墩子下面。
是有一块像岛一样的地方的，然后他也不会游泳，他等于就被困在那儿了。
它相当于什么呢？相当于一个城市版的荒岛余生。
所以这个戏的。
是写的很有意思。
他就在这个荒岛上开始野外生存。
但是呢又看得见城市的喧哗。
很宽的河嘛，那这个。
湖心岛上生活。
但是它资源挺丰富的，因为垃圾飘过来的很多，连洗发水都有，他没那么惨啊。
所以说这个故事很有意思。
呃，呃，我不多剧透，大家自己去看，非常棒，非常呃工整，非常漂亮的剧本啊，这剧本可以打100分的。
那就是激励事件开场呀，上来就跳跳。
씀搞실 용기가 생긴.
参密的。
是过巴龙的车。
我们说他就是把激励事件稍微往前提了一下。那你说来我们说正常的一个戏先铺垫再激励。那这个戏他把激励事件先先说了，那他不铺垫吗？
他只是提前他先跳桥跳江，跳完江以后，在这个湖心岛醒来。
醒来之后发现自己被困在这儿了。然后呢，他想游泳游到。
对岸去，但其实他不会游泳，所以扑腾了几下之后就。
就被淹了，然后被水淹的时候。
我们说一个人。
临死的时候会。
快速的脑子里面过自这个这个像过幻灯片一样过自己的一生嘛，他就是被淹的，喘不上气来的时候，脑子里面开始回想他自己人生的。
一幕一幕。
然后呢，被淹的很惨，然后呢被淹的很惨，然后呃好朋友爬下来之后呢，打电话求救。
依次打给他的。
女朋友呀、妈呀什么的。
通过他们对他的态度和跟他聊天的内容，把他的失败的现状交代的明明白白清清楚。
就是一个。
狗不理。
好人嫌的、失败的中年男人又欠债，又分手。爹妈嫌他没出息。
没钱是吧？就是这么一个中年男人，所以他就是把肌背往前一提，然后呢积完了之后，让你引人入胜之后呢，迅速的把现状都给你补上了。
现状都给你补上。
的东西都给你补上。所以说这就是激励开场。好吧，举这么几个例子，大家去理解一下。
就是就是你一看这好玩，哎，拿过来先用先看。
对吧是个很常见。
还有一种很常见的啊。
还有一种很常见的啊，我们说有也有前十开场。
全是开张。
这个啊也跟常规很接近，就也不难。因为前十啊，我曾经在课上不让大家写前十，我没有完全不让你们写啊。我的意思是你们尽量少写前十少写，除非很有趣，除非真的很有意思。
我们说前史是个啥？
前史实际上是现状的延伸。
比如说。
你这个现状是个啥？
是你这个很落魄，很孤僻，对吧？然后你前十是你小时候。
家庭不幸福，被虐待。
那么前十其实是你现状的原因，是你现状的延伸。
所以他往往讲在什么地方啊，就是讲在片头。
甚至是先前十再进。
片头进那个片头什么的，然后再到现状。
很多电影是这么搞。
特别多。
我之前举过例子的像。
泰迪熊。
泰迪熊那个男主角小时候不受待见吗？小时候不受待见，没人搭理他，对吧？一帮小孩在那揍一个。
犹太小孩儿。
他想过去跟着一块玩，没想到打人的也嫌弃他，连那个挨揍的犹太小孩也都说滚对吧？
就是没有人跟他玩，这不就是前史嘛？小时候的故事，然后再进现状。
It has been said that magic vanished from our world a long time.
And that humanity can no longer fulfill its desires through the power of wishes.
To those who have lost the wondrous vision of childhood eyes submitted here is the story of a little boy and a magical Christmas wish.
Change his life.
好任。
Began in 1985 in a town just outside Boston.
It was Christmas Eve and all the children were in high spirits. That special time of year when Boston children gather together and beat up the Jewish kids. He.
跳我。
But there was one child who wasn't in such good spirits, little John Bennet, that one boy in every neighborhood who just has a tough time making friends.
John longed with all his heart for that one true friend that he could call his own.
And he knew that if he ever found that friend, he would never let him go.
我们说前十的很多的电影里面很多的啊那个那个。
有一部很没有节操的电影叫拉丁情人。
讲什么呢？
讲一个男的。
小伙子。
拉丁小伙帅呃就拉丁帅哥。
就是天天找富婆的一个故事。
开场是什么？开场就是他小时候他小时候他家里很穷，然后呢，但是他爸爸。
呃，妈妈都很勤劳。
很勤劳，很很努力的生活。
但是呢一场灾难夺走了他爸爸的生命，还让他家里倾家荡产。
也就是开场是什么意思呢？就是勤劳的人没有好报，然后呢，他就看着一本。
那种类似于。
福鲁斯杂志，有钱人的杂志那种一本杂志，只让照片对他妹妹说。
说我要成为这样的人。
啊，他们妹妹说啊，你要成为这样的富豪吗？就是不不不，我不要成为这样的富豪，这个富豪很累的，我要成为富豪，后面站着的这个女模特。
但他是个男孩吧，等于是他长大了之后就开始帮富婆。
I was the hardest working person I ever met, spending almost every day of the year on the road.
whenever he had time off, he would race home to see us.
Even if he had to drive all night.
My Papa always said you get what you work for, not what you wish for so much for hard work.
看一下。
里面微味的镜片送红送的方便？
能吒饭。
要给你洗头我的给你弄那个的感觉。
那如梦。
我也在了你。
那个给弄的不弄上。
一动给我。
セ空大还 들어は。
你说来米米。
那那呢。
여给了苏又给了那呀。
也挺有意思的一个电影啊。
还有那个银河护卫队啊。
银河护卫队那个那个那个那个星爵。
开场是他小时候他。
他妈妈临死。
呃，弥留之际那场戏嘛，然后他跑出去被外星人给。
给绑架了。
你妈妈背口。
Have you been fun with the other boys again, baby?
黑人。
orator奶粉。
Mshed it with the stick.
So like your daddy.
你 even look back。
He was哪。
You got a present there for Peter, don't you?
Such good care of you.
At least until your daddy comes back to catch you.
嘿。
可人嗯。
得更得门。
走走啊。
哦。
here蹲下。
给。
那个前十很有趣啊，也交代了他为什么会出现在外星球吗？
他被外星人绑架了嘛，那就是就是前十嘛。
很多啊这样的电影特别多，有一部电影也很没有节操的。
叫爸爸的好儿子。
那个桑德勒和三表哥。
演父子。
这部电影非常没有节操啊，前史是什么呢？就是桑德勒年轻的时候，小时候上初中的时候。
跟老师有一腿，然后呢。
师生恋那不叫练啊，就是跟老师有一腿，结果还把老师给呃呃怀孕了。
怀孕了之后，等于是他上初中的时候，就他老师还把这个孩子生下来了。
然后他老师就去坐牢了嘛，跟未成年人嘛，那肯定得去坐牢，等于是呃。
初中生带着一个儿子长大。
然后呢，前十就是这段校园的荒唐事儿。
ep I heard is freaking man serious beside I'm just not into anymore I'm the that's not what I.
我们的 women。
Mary.
I got Van weekend time up is Miss Mc and that's but I am your teacher not your miss girlfriends let's just start the summer couple of hand jobs no't get all right away that is a month's de.
hand job,I don't know but think开 walk我。
Can I go to the bathroom No, no talking in deten, Mr. Bger All right, I'm sorry for what I did, I promise I would do it again.
You're in a lot of trouble, Donnie.
Wait you're not going to tell my dad are you, he'll kick my ass he's crazy What were you trying to do anyway and press your friends you know youre?
You have a little crush on me, no, no, so you don't want me.
No。
Yeah, I don't know what I'm supposed to say right now, iss that gum in your mouth, Donnie?
You,I've been watching you all year, Donni.
When you hit that shot to beat Fairfield and you were jumping up and down and your little Larryrry bird short shorts and sweating like a jar of pickles in the hot sun, oh god.
还有小孩。
Is this really happening?
这死 happen。
It's happening right now in my office.
Okay, awesome, so I'm telling how do you want to do it because I made sex before lots of ways, so you want to go straight to hand jobs or eat me out or taking me from behind I'll teach you I'm a Per.
快家。
Oh my god.
swings, you know, it's more than just some new sensation Well the kidten is to lose and sleep and don't go home week, You know it's more than just an aation in theo.
能连不去的。
AndIf I'm elected eager class president, I promise to so good at this.
I promise to do my best to lower prices at the school stores and my practice is really bad off.
的。
啊。
My dad's going kick my ass.
I'm aware that a lot of people think that this young man is not really a victim but someone that's living the ultimate teenage boy's fantasy.
This is a serious crime, Mary Beth Mcgarrickll rise for sentencing.
The fact that this relationship has resulted in a pregnancy in you show absolutely no remorse saying, and I quote, I would fuck that kid again and again, he makes me feel like there's a rainbow coming out of my beva.
Leavsby absolutely no choice but to levy the maximum penalty 30 years in the Massachusetts women's penitentiary and furthermore, the court grants custody of the unborn child to Donald Burger's father as until Donald turns 18 at which time he will assume full custody.
I'll never stop loving you That is just fucking mental.
然后故事正文开始就是他儿子长大以后不认他爹三表哥这个角色不认桑德勒。
然后呢，父子两人的呃父子两人的戏吧。
那这个前十也特别有意思，而且很有用是吧？这个也是前十开场的一个例子。为什么前十开场这么多无节操呢？而且全是电影给大家举个剧的吧。
那个那个暴君。
有一个美剧叫暴君，我我也给大家说过啊，那个剧呃第一集非常值得看，因为第一集开场开的很猛，后面有点掉链子。
但是开场开的很猛。
讲的是一个。
中东的独裁国家的。
公子哥公子，因为对他父亲不满。
跟他父亲理念不合，然后呢，自己在美国。
读书当医生，过一个很正常的人生，美国式的人生。
呃，拒绝面对他他的过去，他他他的家乡，他的家乡是一个独裁国家，他父亲是那个国家的暴君嘛。
然后那他的开场就是。
他的各种做噩梦对吧？他跑步的时候也想到他小时候那些一幕一幕，他是因为他在那个独裁国家长大嘛，他小时候还甚至还。
被他父亲逼得杀过人，对吧？他亲眼看到那个国家的残暴。
很多人在那个。
袭迹中死去。
炸弹袭击。
所以说他就是不断的在回忆。
返回做开场。
。
button。
How do you expect people to respect you if you can't dress yourself?
起来了。
a girl wave.
36回定。
my son will got that ribbon.
It is a great honor to be standing here with you, the good people of mine.
His ground one stained with the blood and tears of conflict.
买的酸枣飘不腿。
is more just steel and concrete, it is a symbol that despite our differences.
就是我们说前十在之前在上课的时候啊，我曾经。
比较严肃的说过。
少用前十，少用闪悔，为什么呢？不是不好。
是你们没到没有到时候，同学们，你们还没有到可以驾驭好这种东西的时候。
你们用不是给这个剧本加分，不是给这个故事加分，是给这个故事减分了。所以我不让你们用。因为你们用那些玩意儿的时候是想省事儿。
只想过多的交代之前的事情，过多的交代小时候的事情。
导致这个故事头重脚轻，所以我当时不让你们用。
并不是说这个东西一定就是不好，一定就是不对。好吧，你看这也是一种情况，而且这种情况呢。
离常规方式。
也不远。
也不远，就是说也不会特别。
怪也不会特别难，因为前史就是现状的延伸嘛。然后这个这个激励事件，它虽然接在它虽然是在后面的，但是它其实就接在铺垫后面，而且它属于第一幕里面的呀。
第一幕就开始了呀，对吧？
所以说。
这两种方法啊就是虽然非常规，但是离常规也不是很远。
然后呢，下面第三种。
这写不下了。
写这儿啊。
第三种。
这写不下，我写这儿了啊，我们说第三种。
非常规的。
把后面的东西提上来，提啥呢？
提的最狠的。
他他就是提结局呀。
提结局呀。
结局瞪过来。
对不对？那是最狠了。
最吸引人了。
当然他难度也大，风险也大，对吧？
我们说提结局，或者说叫提。
悬念。
最大的悬念提上来。
结局和大悬念。
这种开场方式。
也很多啊。
我们一下就能想到的。
啊，就有。
比如说。
恕罪。
这是奥斯卡得奖的剧本啊，宿罪上来就是新郎丢了，哪去了？
然后呢，所有的伴郎都断片了。
都回忆不起来，，我们到底干了什么，新郎到底丢哪儿去了？是死是活。
对吧。
恕罪典型的就是把结局。
提上来，把大悬念提上来。
咋办？丢了。
让我给。
一不而代。
Hey, youve reached Doug, sorry, Mr. Call, please leave a name and number and I'll get back to you.
嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟。
Reach Dr.war Price with F Intry, please leave a message.
你有力量。
Hey, this is Phil, leave me message we done, do me in favor, don't text me this gay.
Anyth keep going straightmail Well there has to be an explanationie casinos''s nos's probablyer and you never walk away from the table when you're on aer You do if you're getting married.
Hello, Tracy it's Phil Phil, where the hell are you guys Im freaking out there, listen.
呃。
We fucked up What are you talking about The bachelor party the whole night.
He's got out of control.
We lost Doug what?
We can't find Doug what are you saying Phil, we're getting married in five hours?
Yeah。
That's not going to happen.
很典型的，也是一下就抢到的盗梦空间。
上来就是盗梦空间开场第一场戏是啥？迪卡普里奥趴在沙滩上，然后恍惚中还看到他的妻子，看到他的孩子，然后分不清这是现实还是梦境，第几层梦境，对吧？我是谁，我在哪，到底怎么回事，搞不清楚，那就是结局嘛，结局就是那那那场戏。
いょと来早しや가るぞ!
结局或者大悬念往上一提。
你的故事。
你的这个开场。
非常贵，也马上拉人了。这种方法其实其实是。
最狠的最通俗的也是最常用的。
比如说。
再举几个美剧啊，我今天举的很多美剧的例子，你们都可以去搜着看一看，因为都是好美剧啊。
今天相当于给大家推荐了很多剧，我再举几个美剧的例子。
有一个美剧叫黑色星期一。
相信很多同学都没有看过啊，黑色星期一。
讲的是什么故事呢？讲的是是华尔街炒股票的那些金融公司，有点像华尔街之达啊，就那些公司的人各种尔虞我诈，各种哎呀巧取豪夺，炒股票对吧？非法买卖各种那个呃这个这个这个酒吃肉林。
物欲横流对吧分分钟几百万上下的。
那种生活，纸醉金迷的生活。
就这么一个一个美剧。
开场第一场戏就是。
股灾的一天，黑色星期一嘛，有一个星期一是股灾，然后逛荡。
一个人跳楼。
砸在了一辆豪车上。
然后镜头拍了这个人的西装，这个人的领带的特写，领带上的那个。
那个那个那个我因为不不穿西服，我不知道那叫什么，加在领带上那个玩意儿叫什么。
啊，不管它叫什么嘛，反正夹在领带上的一个一个类似于宝石一样的东西，对吧？反正给了各种特写。
但是就是没有拍脸。
然后哈就这场戏结束金正文。
然后呢。
你就会在这个戏里面开始找这个跳楼的人到底是谁？这一帮。
花尔皆知狼，这一帮他妈天天分分钟几百万上下的这帮纸醉金迷的家伙，最后谁死了，谁跳的楼，对吧？你就会发现哎这个西装好像是那个人了，领带好像是那个人了，那个那个那个领带夹子好像是又是谁的？
就是给你很多悬念。
就是最大的悬念，其实也是结局嘛，结局就是跳楼嘛。
就是你过这种生活没有好结局。
这就是。
很典型的这个美剧大家可以去看一下。然后一说这个跳楼这个死，我又想起一个美剧，去年呢非常棒的一个美剧叫最响亮的声音。
是一个。
类似于纪录片一样的自传体一样的那一个美剧，叫最响亮的声音，大家也去可以去看一下。因为它是根据真人真事写的嘛，纪传体嘛，所以他也不需要什么隐藏，他不需要什么制造隐藏结局什么的。上来第一场戏就是这个男主角。
死了。
就是这个男主角死了，然后嘞，应该是发那个。
类似于新闻吧。
新闻报道吧，就说谁谁谁于呃这个这个哪年哪月哪日记时记分。
对吧因兵去世之类的，应该是这样啊，我不得记得不是很清楚，大家自己去看吧，反正开场就是这个家伙死了，这个男主角死了。
I know what people are going to say about me, I can pretty much pick the words for you.
right wingoid主角。
把结局大悬念往上一提。
我们说这个方法简单粗暴。
有效。
在某些某某些故事中也是适用的。
还有没有还有还有第四种。
这种怎么描述呢？
怎么描述呢？
其实是把。
某个片段。
我们说既不是激励，也不是前十，也不是结局。它是把中段的某个片段，中段的某个片段提到前面来了，也有很多这样的戏。
那中段的某个片段提到前面来了。
咱们的课程不是搞分类的啊，我们是搞实用的。所以我们必须研究明白怎么提的，怎么选的，为什么提这一段？
我跟你说啊。
他一般是提什么啊？
他能提。
体一场能代表这个戏。
逆境了。
或者是说叫叫代表这个戏的。
色调。
或者是说代表这个戏的价值的。
这么一场戏。
他们也不是瞎提呀，你从中段提一场戏，你也不能瞎提呀，对不对？你得是代表这场戏就是。
虽然它不是结局，但是你提这场戏呢也是能把这场整个故事的调调，整个故事的价值。
或者是说叫主题吧。
他有点偏主题的感觉。
比如说还珠格格就是这样。
还珠格格的第一场戏。
是啥？
老片子啊比很多同学很多同学的年龄都大。
还珠格格是我年轻的时候特别小时候啊，我小时候特别火的火遍全国的片子群阿姨。
赵薇出道的片子。
还珠格格第一场戏就是小燕子坐在那个花轿上招摇过世，然后呢。
围观的人群众都在那啊，还珠格格来了，还珠格格来了。然后呢，紫薇就林夕如那个角色，紫薇就趴在墙头上看。
他抢了我的格格位置，我才是格格，对吧？
是不是小燕子，你看你看是不是是不是是他没错，是小燕子。
小燕子小燕子小燕子。
收了一个民间女子做义女，封为还珠格格，今天就是带她进城吗？
不子。
听说这个还珠格格神通广大，换岁颜喜欢的不得了诶。
我叔叔啊在经里当差，听说这个格格来头不小，说是收什么玉女啊，搞不好啊，就是金枝玉叶，谁都知道皇上最喜欢为服出巡的，东南西北到处跑。
小姐，他骗了你，他拿走了你的信物，他真的成了合罪了。
什我。
他不是格哥，他是骗子，我要是向为皇燕我照有皇大地。
皇豪姐，你怎么这对我？放老燕我。
主小皇上皇上骗了皇皇小姐被骗了我夫哥哥。
回。
小姐，你回来，把拉下去如果你是哥哥，那我是什么？
小叶子，你为什么要骗我？我好像听到紫薇的声音，我这么相信。
小爷姐人，你给我找去，小。
这不是结局，对吧？这是一很中段的中前部分的一场戏。但是呢它代表了整个整个戏的主题，就是这两个女孩换了位置，换了身份。小燕子顶替了紫薇，成为了。
格格对吧？其实紫薇才是呃大明湖畔夏雨河的女儿嘛。
就是它主题这样的例子也很多啊，特也特别多。比如说还有什么呢？
还有那个。
我也课上推荐过的有个电影叫触不可及。
触不可及，法语版和英语版各有一版。
嗯，我们以美英语版举例啊，就美国那版。因为凯文哈特和老白演的嘛，那个我比较。
印象比较深，他的开场是什么？他的开场是凯文哈特开车拉着老白闯红灯。
就是两个男主角开着豪车闯红灯，然后被警察拦住了，然后他们俩开始装怂，对吧？因为那个老白确实是残疾人嘛，然后那个那个呃卡文哈特就说他癫嫌犯了，抽风了，对吧？必须快速送他去医院，所以我才超速才闯红灯。
。
在主00的路。
100 bucks you owe me what your silence was your bet, you know that, right?
8路的靠在8路的看。
your look Colom d quadriple.
We want to wait to the hospital, the man is having a seizure.
Oh y'all go to take your time he's probably got a few minutes before theto sets in morto Quad paralyzeds special are your still standing check out?
you the bigger problem I' get to the hospital ambulance you think an ambulance is in this car?
嗯啊。
Jus,你 really sold that，我 didn你。
rig阿to。
就他俩瞎胡搞了一场戏很精彩，因为豪车红灯警察这场戏显然很漂亮嘛，所以把它提到前面来，很漂亮的一场戏。但是也代表主题就是两一个黑黑人小子，带着一个残疾富豪，两个人瞎胡闹。
这不就是这部电影的总体的一个色调嘛，总体的调调嘛。
那就是把这场戏提上来也挺有意思那既然说到这个老白，说了触不可及的老白，绝命毒师不也是吗？
绝命毒师的开场戏也是令人印象深刻的开场戏吧。老白穿着个小小短裤，在沙漠里面那个那个很窘很窘很窘迫的在沙漠里面哎，不知道呃这个这个逃命，无所适从而且拿这个摄像机啊有那儿痛哭流涕的。
开临终遗言，然后又拿起一把枪准备跟谁拼了那种感觉。
那也不是结局，那就是很中很中前部的一场戏。
啊。
My name is Walter Hartwell White, I live 308 Nero Royaly La, albuquerque, New Mexico 87104 through all law enforcement entities this is not an admission or guilt.
I am speaking to my family now.
。
泰ler。
You are the love of my life.
I hope you know that.
包点精来。
You're my big man.
ThereThere are going to be some things and things that you'll come to learn about me in the next few days, I just want you to know that no matter how it may look, I only had you in my heart.
绝面读是讲啥？
讲的是一个老实巴交的化学老师。因为。
走投无路。
这个绝症。
决定铤而走险开始。
制毒贩毒。
那他的基调就是。
窘迫吧。
他的机跳就是。
窘迫和出丑嘛。
这是观众可以可以预见到的一种意意境，可以预见到的一种色调。
那你就把它提提上来。
给观众看得过瘾嘛？
这也是一行很典型的。
其实还有那个戏。
也挺有意思的，御前教育。
有个电影叫御前教育，也是美国喜剧中心出的啊，就是讲一个富豪呃这个这个。
经济犯罪。
他也是那种股这这这个高级金融分析师之类的啊，什么投资家、理财师之类的那种职位。因为经济犯罪。
要被。
被判入狱了，然后一个月倒计时。
他呢因为从小就是什么各种名校啊，什么富人社区啊，对监狱一无所知。他对美国监狱的认知跟咱们差不多，就是美国监狱里面肯定是那种。
各种大纹身，大肌肉男，然后欺负你，而且还要干你对吧？其实他也是这种想象。
从电影里面了解美国监狱，然后他就吓死了。
他就吓死了，然后呢，他他他就想了一个什么主意呢？
他学的我的他他因为从小品学兼优嘛，对他就觉得那我既然要入狱了，还有一个月时间，我要学习一下监狱里面的生存技巧，然后呢，他就去找了一个黑人洗车工。
就是凯文哈特喜剧中间就是那个那个。
猝不可及里面那个小配荐员小哥凯文哈特演的，他去找凯文哈特培训自己。
就说我给你钱。
培训我一下如何在监狱中生存。
海文哈克呢就是一个。
其实也是没进过监狱，一个很老实巴交的人。
但是就是他一方面很缺钱，想挣这个钱。另一方面呢，觉得这个家伙种族歧视呀，你看我是黑人，你就觉得我肯定进过监狱，肯定了解监狱了，然后他就决定挣他的钱。
就是这么一个故事，就是一个没有进监监，没有进过监狱的小黑人。
嗯收了钱培训一个富豪。
呃，这个如何进监狱？
就是这么一个故事。
他的开场戏第一场就是这个男主角，就是这个白日富豪。
对着镜头大哭。
一直哭。
。
哈。
开一场戏非常简单粗暴，就是这个主角一直哭一直哭。
大哭。
哭的非常窘迫，一个大男人。
然后呢，开场戏完了之后就是他很潇洒的人生。
3000平米的大房子，游泳池，家里佣人十几个，对吧？媳妇儿像模特一样，维密模特一样穿的那种比基尼，然后他自己在家里对吧？很潇洒的那种。
生活。
跟你的开场反差极大，而且让观众会觉得我操。
这个大伙后面会有很惨。
会哭死。
对吧他就是把一个带着色调，带着情境的一小场提上来，整个就。
记就很有意思。
还有什么？
再给大家举个例子。
这一节课光举例子，举了几十个。
大家回去可以都看一看。还有那个。
还有一个韩国电影叫情侣门。
情侣们。
大家也可以去去去去看一下那个戏非常有意思啊，写了也很有意思，应该也是得过剧本奖。
得过剧本剧本的奖项了一个一个一个电影，所以强烈推荐大家看一看。
那个电影讲啥呢？讲的是爱情故事，讲的是各种。
就是呃什么叫爱情？什么叫缘分？类似于这样的主题的一个故事。
他的开场就是。
他的开场就是采访各种小情侣，哎，你们是怎么相遇的？然后你们俩是怎么认识的？哎，你是哪天爱上对方，你们是怎么发觉对方是你的。
这个这这这个命中注定的就是类似于这样一个采访的魂简。
嗯。
지금 바로 시작하요。
哎了。
재밌을 거야。
그러니까 그게 한 9월 말쯤 됐나?
9 월 21 일 나 탄시3 지훈 코 디테 디테 그날 회사 일로 외근 중이 었 거든요.
평 았으면 지하철 을탔을 텐데 그날 따라 막 시 원한 바람도 불고 부는 게.
이상하게 버스가 타고 싶더라고요 저도요.
갑자기 버스가 급전 거를 한 거예요.
병원 응급실에 실려서 2시간 만에에 깨어났는데.
친구가 거의 죽어가 얼굴로 거기 서 있는 겁니다.
嗯。
그렇게 시작 된 거 죠.
운명처럼那就是那就是卡着主题，卡着色调来的嘛。
对吧那个也是非常典型。
非常典型。
所以你看啊。
这就是咱们这节课的内容。
我们说。
如何写出？
像隐秘的角落这样的。
哪有人的开场？
啥叫男人的开场？其实就是。
引人入胜的开场，出人意料的开场。
我们说开场其实从这个维度分分两种，一种拿人，一种人家不拿人，不拿人，不拿人的好处优点不是给大家说了吗？对吧？人家娓娓道来，慢慢进戏也是有好处的，也有它的优势。呃常规开场很多都是那种。
我们说那拿人的也分两种，就是常规方法开场也可以做到引人入胜。
然后但是更多的是非常规。
方式基本上分这四种，对吧？你要么用激励掀开，你要么用一个前史，你能写出一个牛逼前史。
对吧也可以，或者你直接就喊白蛋。
大结局，大悬念就瞪上来也可以。然后再就是。
从中段找一个有代表性的。
或者是有意思的。
一场戏。
提上来也可以作为开场。我们说基本上就是这几种方式。
基本上就是这几种方式。
哎。
可以拿人可以。
拿人的话。
可以常规，也可以非常规。非常规的话，四种方式逻辑很清楚了，是吧？
我们来试一把。
我们来试一下啊。
举个例子吧。
我们说假设那个药神那个。
我们说药神。
是常规开场。
是不拿人的那种。
我给大家说了嘛，人家不不需要不需要，人家也不想。我们说如果药神这个。
剧本。
是攒写咱手欠。
手欠儿想拿人儿。
用非常规的方式开场，想拿人。
怎么办？
怎么开？
我们说。
当然我们可以用那个吧。
情绪大悬念提上来吧。
把结局提上来吧。
审判那场戏吗？
我们不就是可以提上来吗？
徐峥在法庭上穿的那个橘红色的那个监狱坎肩马甲。
坐在法庭上，然后那个审判长。
宣布，比如说被告人有罪咣当。
对吧或者是徐峥最后的那段结案陈词也可以，对吧？我承认我的犯罪，对吧？但是我真的不是为了钱，我承认是认就是他那段很还比较有意思，有力量的那段自己的那段独白吧。
写案全词就说那这场戏提到开场。
然后再进行。
可以吧。
就是说我不是药神这个电影，我们把最后法庭的那场戏。
提下来。
可以吧。
这是一种方式。
非常贵。
我们说第二种。
我们找一个能够代表意境和色调的。
中断的一个片段。
提上来。
我不是要钱。
可以吗？
也可以找。
我们说结局这个其实有点类似于，比如说像最响亮的声音那样，你上来就告诉我最后这个人肯定是蹲大狱了，对吧？上来就告诉你，他的结局就是进去了。
不用没什么好讨论的，他肯定要进去的。
嗯。
那么中间这个片段。
我们说整个戏来说，他是卖药。
而且是非法卖药。
经常要被女人撵
被警察撵。
那我们可以提那一段。
他跟黄毛。
在码头开着一辆小车装着要冲关的那一场。
被警察追走投无路，拼了，一定要通出去。
被警察追的到处黄毛不是那一场开车戏，而且黄毛在那场戏死了。
我们可以把那场戏提前。
就是说开场戏用。
橘峥跟黄毛。
在码头里被警察追的走投无路，最后决定冲。
最后决定冲卡一脚油门嗡过去。
然后再开车。
可以吧。
你看这也是一种开场方式，也也也OK，也不影响故事的整个调调。
第三种方式我们说什么？
啊，激励事件开场？
我们说我不是要人的激密事件开场也可以吗？
可以改成激率时间开场。
也可以啊。
但是你要把激励事件写的有趣啊，他现在的激励事件，我们说有两种理解方式，一种是从理解为从吕受义进门开始，对吧？吕受义来委托他。
去印度带药。
就是还有一种理解方式是就是他爹他爹生病，病危需要一大笔手术费开始。
我们如果用激励事件开场，那需要把激励事件改得有趣，否则那提下来没有意义的呀。我们说你这场戏提到前面。
作为开场，你必须你这场戏有看头。
才能达到拿人的目的嘛。
这两场戏都是有看头的，你提上来。
那激励事件它本身这场激励事件没有看头。
我们提上来的话。
得改。
比如说我们以吕受益进门这一场说啊。
开场就是第一场戏，我不是要晨的第一场戏开始就是这个这个徐峥这个角色坐在他的药店里。
然后屡收益。
探头就进来了。
推门探头就出来。
然后开始。
那我们就把这场戏丰富一下，吕受益要来打探一下这个药店有没有。
他必须打斥一下徐峥能不能从印度带药诶。
徐峥虽然是开。
那个那个那个保健品店的性药店的，但是他不一定真的去过印度呀，对吧？所以说吕受义可以这场戏改成吕受义进来试探去。
然后进来之后就开始打听徐峥这些印度神油到底是不是印度的？
你是不是在印度进的对吧？然后两人发生争执争吵。
试探或者是吕受益已经来买过一次药。
这是第二次来来找徐峥说，你的药没用。
是不是不是印度原装的呀，是不是假的呀？然后徐峥跟他说，我他妈自己去印度背回来的之类的。
然后吕受义确定这个人，然后还骂吕受义，你看你这你这脸蜡滑蜡黄的，你可能是自己不行。
你吃仙丹也没用了，哥们，你别对吧？你别说我药不好，是你自己已经无药可救了。然后这样的一场戏。
就比较有意思。
甚至直接在争吵中。
这个吕受义直接晕过去。
吕受义直接晕死过去。
然后这个这个徐峥一看，哎呀。
这个人这体格缺个脸色要死在我这儿是吧？可完了。然后但是。
手里也没有药，然后拿印度神油给。
给李硕益涂一涂人中似么的对吧？那李硕一又醒过来。
就是开场可以用这场戏激励事件。
吕受益来找。
呃，徐峥。
带药。
想办法改一改也可以。
就是说你这个激地事件如果足够有趣，让这个两人不打不相识也可以。
然后那还有就是前十。
如果我不是药神。
开场用前十开。
怎么样能。
那只能用徐峥小时候。
徐峥小时候。
他妈妈。
生病。
然后呢。
那肯定不是白血病，是别的病。
但是也是吃药吃不起。
药吃不起。
然后呢，徐生在那哭，他爸爸也很难过，然后他妈妈从医院里回到家里来。
徐生在那哭着问他爸爸为什么不给妈妈治病，为什么不让妈妈继续住院？然后他爸爸不说话，然后他妈妈反而安慰他说家里没有。
太贵了，是不。
没事，我没事的，你要好好学习。
你钱留着给你读书，你要好好，长大要有出息。就小时候他妈妈也是因为生病过早的。
就就去世了。
这是是徐峥的前世。
然后徐峥听他妈妈生病药吃不起。
从小在他心里埋下了。
阴影就是我长大了。
我妈妈竟然是因为吃药吃不起死的对吧？我长大了一定要开药店。
叫下一个镜头卖卖性药，药店是开了呀，他是在卖印度神油是吧？前使就是暗暗发誓，我长大了一定要开药店，让吃不起药的人有药吃，然后结果是卖性药，就比较讽刺，但是。
后来。
等到他。
遇到吕受益之后，慢慢的在点燃它。
前十。
真的心里的那个萌芽。
买下的那个火种。
等于是这个前十也是有用的。当然这个片儿就比较俗了。
但是商业片也也也也有这么做，我就是给大家举个例子，对吧？如果当然了，都不如现在我不是药神，现在的这种开场方式。
因为他是个纪师风格的片子。
需要搞得太。
他平静的进戏对他来说是最佳选择。
我只是举例子，如果我不是药神，硬要改成非常规开场。
也可以有这。
四种方式。
好吧。
同学们理解了吧？
理解了吧，那这节课就上到这儿了啊。
下课。
嗯。